θετική σκέψει και ήταν κάτι πούμε βοήθησε γιατί είναι πολύ ύκροντα ερχεσα από μια μικρή
χώρα πως είναι κείπρος όταν πας σε αγωνές μεγάλους και αντιμετωπίσεις φθά μεγαθέρεια που πορεί
να μείνε αθλή της που κέρδισε ν αυτό το χρυσώνει το προηγούμενο αλλά νάν από
την είδια χωρά να πειφτιάσεις νιωθης έτσι λιγό μειονεκτικά ότι ενο άγκλως ένω αύσταλος εμπίσομε
να με φάρι αλλά το να δουλέψει σνοητικά κα αντιληφθύσω ότι στο έο της ημέρας
είναι από τοχαίρι σι ότι διάμεχεή τω μια λώσου και ότι αν πρώταπρατοπιστέψει τους δοδιως
και δουλέψεις πως αυτή την καδευτυσή τότε είναι ποολύ πι εύκρονο τα καταθαφέρεις κανάτετις του
εγγιάδι ότι θα το καταφέρεις αλλά υπιθανότητες αυξάνονται πμνοστόχος είπαμε λημπιάδα τουλοαελέ το ποσικτό και
η τελευταία σοσιαστικά και τυταστόχος στόχος ή να δώσω των καέδεροε αυτόν όλ αυτά τα
δε αρχόνια να απολαύσωτ ταξίδι ένα αντέρασι το κίνη τρογιταμένα θα ενα ότι ο ιός
μας θα είναι και σε η λιγιά πλέον ιδικά από τοκσίεξη και μετά ου θα
θυμάται θα ζήσει αυτή την πορεία πολλές φορες ηπάντα δεν είναι αυτά που τους λέμε
λλά είναι αυτά που βλέπουν α π μας και αποκορύβομα να διώσει την εμπιράντρονη πια
γόρα που θα θυμάται σίγουρα ανεξάρτητα από τα αποδελεσμαν σίγουρα όμωςδε στου κριότι τονιρομό είναι
ένα ξαναγό στο βαθρον και εδώ ετσιθρο να διαχωρίσω ότι είναι τον ύρων και δύνα
στόχος πολύ από μας νομιζούει το ύο πράγμα λλά δεν είναι τον γρο είναι κάτι
που δεν εξαρτάτε μόνο από εμας το αν εγώ θα είμασ το βάθριο όχι δεν
εξαταμα από μέναν υπάρχουν πάραπολύ παραγοντές το όμως ιστόχι δηλαδήτω να κάνω κάθει μερινά προπόνηση
να προσότηγια τροφήγμου να κάνω σωστί ζωή να αποκατάσταση και όλα τα κομμάτια του πάζολνα
πουεκεί που πρέπει κια να δώσουν τις μεγαλίες πιθανόιο του παύλουν να πετύχει των ιρώ